what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to willow the anxiety
and tyler cole performance um meet me at
our spot before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of our daily
my daily videos say are it's just me
here
[Music]
when i wake up i can't even stay up i
slept through the
[Music]
up for day
baby
[Music]
wow this song is so pretty
oh my gosh that's so pretty
her voice is phenomenal i don't care
what anyone says
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe we can take a charge
just give me such vibes of like a song i
would listen to driving in a car
like maybe it's because i've talked
about it in the song
but this just kind of takes me back to
like teenage years when you're just like
driving in the car with your friends and
it's so
[Music]
find us funny
give me a spot but something i want to
show you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh
did you hear that harmony at the end i
don't
i do not care what anyone says that was
beautiful literally beautiful
oh my gosh i gave that performance
literally a five out of five
like that was that was phenomenal
um let me know in the comments
what you guys thought um did you liked
it
did you not i don't know either way
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell i'll talk to
you guys next time